when Tate and I were having a
conversation together
and
in the interview one of the things I
said is
very hard to earn sane status in any
space
very hard but when you earn Saint status
it's mathematically
let me rephrase it the chances of you
getting canceled it's point zero zero
zero one percent it's very small okay
what do we mean by this Joe Rogan is
saying status they try to cancel them
they couldn't do it why not though who
has Joe's back think about who was Joe's
back actually let's say it who has Joe's
back Spotify who else had Joe's back
Russell Brand who else
so many people had his back yeah
political figures that the opposition
was like oh we can't cancel this
guy true because he's our insane status
yeah
when you haven't earned Saint status yet
you have to understand that part yeah if
you act like you've earned sane status
so for example Tate who has tapes back
that's a powerful figure yeah I mean his
whole cult no but that's not that's not
but that's not you're saying like a real
power who has his back no one really no
one yeah no one who has his back no one
hundreds of millions of people if not
billions have his back but what's their
level of influence to have their back
Joe had UFC now watch what Logan is
doing WWE so there's a part of it where
Triple H on those guys could have his
back right each if you look at every one
of these guys that make it to the
highest level you have to position
yourself in a way to have same status
you you first start off with protection
you got protection right now from who
these guys how big are they right now
massive they're everywhere right that is
a form of protection okay and eventually
you got to become a flag carrier for
them where you're getting loud and
here's who we are here's what they're
doing you're showing a lot of gratitude
to them for what they're doing for you
the opportunity they've given you
and then eventually the market falls in
love some heavyweight people fall in
love with you then you're not canceled
because you have same status so you know
you
strategy of a guy like Tate you know as
as much as the world is enamored by him
he's got to kind of look politically
yeah if Trump was President you think
they would have built that uh take
quicker probably you think Biden's going
to bail out the uh Biden couldn't bail
out the Greiner in Russia let alone
bailing out he doesn't care about Tate's
message Tate's message is not his
message so these are the things that you
have to be some of it happens accent I'm
sure Joe Rogan didn't do it
intentionally Joe I'm gonna go get
that's not how Joseph we had dinner
he's the most chillest he's the guy you
want as a friend as a brother as an
uncle as a cousin as a guy to be in
business with that's that guy right but
you have to think about long term who
are those guys that are going to be in
your Corners so Saint status now I'm
going to talk about Jordan Peterson sure
because he's under attack by the
psychologist Board of Ontario in Canada
yep I'm sure you've heard of that is
that because he doesn't have Saint
status is that because he doesn't have
he has big names backing him up like
like people will come out you'll
interview him you'll talk about him so
why do you think he's in that position
as well is it a Canadian thing maybe
listen who is who so who who's trying to
cancel him Canada who cares true it's
true there's 30 million people there's
but it's not even Canada it's the
psychology of whatever they want him to
come out and take some education
you're talking about yeah yeah it's
crazy and there's certain things in life
that you're like who wants to cancel me
totally fine with that yeah I'm okay
with that so
no there is certain Community the bigger
you get you cannot expect to have
everybody like you because then you have
to act then you have to be fake that's a
very hard thing to do and the audience
is not gonna the audience can for sure
tell when you're fake or you're acting
yep I told Joe I said Joe everybody that
I bring on the podcast that's never been
on your podcast first thing they asked
me when the interview is done with hey
man can you tell you know can you put in
a good word into to to me and you know
to Joe and just you know I'm like bro I
said Joe I never bring it up to you yeah
I don't bring it up to you know I tell
them I said listen you want to have a
Beyond Joe spot yes DMO he likes it'll
do that and then Joe said he said look I
only interview people I want to
interview
you know guys will come in and they'll
say through Bookers they'll say hey if
you ever want to interview this guy
interview these three people hoping to
want to get to this guy fine that's you
want to play that card no problem
we'll give you a hundred thousand
dollars if you have this person on your
podcast to interview because we'll get
these out no
you can tell Joe's audience yeah because
Joe interviewed so he wants to interview
yeah that's why you love Joe yeah so the
brand cannot be watered down
please